[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
cause
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
dragon ball z world championship
tenkaichi online master challenge i'm
your host with the most acoustics here
with the lovely big puppy julo himself
hey cool six hey hey chad
hey dragon ball
thanks
oh it's all to be cool all right posing
it's been a long day for some of these
players and now it has come down to the
top eight of a tournament where first
place gets 200 points
in the world championship run our top
eight contestants right now are
before you can start that let me break
it down for you guys right so the
tenkaichi online challenge has a
breakdown of points uh regarding each
event today's event is a tenkaichi
online master challenge first place gets
200 points second 150 third 100 470
fifth 45 so on so on now remember guys
this may be the only master event for
the east but as long as people continue
to go to their other local events online
it's still possible to remake these
points remember if you have a certain
amount of entrance in each tournament
you can still get points 64 plus can
have a maximum of
148 plus 70 uh 32 or 45 and 16 with 25
so remember no matter who wins today
there's still a chance to make a
comeback because the tournament is still
running on
sir yes sir if there's any confusion
let's take a screenshot of that points
breakdown so you can know what exactly
y'all receive
when y'all pretty much participate in
these tournaments and please
exactly all right uh moving on the
regional finals for each of each region
is happening in the month of december
the 4th and 5th of december is going to
be the european regional finals of the
world championship uh the 12th and 11th
is going to be the finals for the usa
and the 18th and 19th is going to be the
finals for japan
all right
i think tonight is going to be very good
in our top eight we have a obelisk
on the winner's side going against kite
we got a meezy going against hilari aka
hikari aka the demon child also on
winner's sides for the semifinals and
then loser's side we have vermeer and a
very interesting uh interesting underdog
of the tournament insert coin one of our
few non uh non
north american uh finalists in here uh
and then we have bag of thot and tk
breaker
josie what you thinking about this right
now so um first and foremost um as the
current leaderboard stand hakari
is going to france he's in third you
know being that coaches first he already
qualified so his first place is somewhat
non-existent right
he's already there so it's all about
getting second and third in his
leaderboards and right now is dismantle
x and hakari right so hakari winning a
big tournament at city ma'am shout outs
to bob163 um he gained 100 points he was
in fifth sixth place with 125 points but
jumped on the leaderboard and got 225
points there earned him a third spot and
today is very very interesting if if i'm
the match dismantle x
i thought he was a shooter for france
but he got a knife today
and he lost a very important match
against vermont vermont is in that
fourth spot he's trying to get to france
food so
if i'm dismantling i'm wishing for the
worst for hikari and vermin because you
don't want to pull out at that 2-3 spot
right you want to still be in the
running to go to france oh we're going
right into it oh wow and our first match
is already starting is that my uh
semi-finals of winners kite versus
obelisk let's get it going baby
from connecticut obvious from ohio
this is going to be interesting guys so
kite is a very good player he's very
well he's pretty good offline as well
doesn't do all too much online but today
he said you know what we're here for it
he's going going up against obvious
obvious is dangerous because he's one of
those guys and he's looking like one of
those knights that he'll just get second
at a bracket right second or third
i've had the i've had the honor of like
playing kite offline when i when i made
the trip to boston very solid player uh
yeah but he plays kid blue so he's still
wack so you really don't
all right
all right
all right so this is an interesting
choice i haven't seen obviously uh team
choices recently but he's going with the
the kepler 21 in quillins
definitely interesting
all right he's gonna get the first hit
inside knockdown it's a setup
okay
so so funny enough that uh a lot of
capitalists like to do that because it
covers all tech situations right there
um the only way to really get out of it
you have to like me
or wake up but it's actually pretty hard
to do
he called he called censor being i
imagine he meant to do rocks there but
they come out oh he's stringing up but
we're blocking all right
classes
all right okay yeah he tried to read the
up back right there he's gonna get
punishment oh we dropping loops though
baby first loop for the game first loop
in the game that ain't looking good for
kite he gets opened up
all right
all right not gonna be able to get the
kill here definitely going into 21 level
three
um i think the the the kefla at level
one actually bounces her slightly out
the corner as possible to steal yep it
does oh
oh but it doesn't get decided oh plus
rings though hold that
look at the scene joe he was able to
block that raw attack doesn't get the
conversion though if this is
so let's take
okay
no no this is good this is good okay
okay i like that bring him back into the
corner try to go for the reset wow wow
maybe maybe he could kill he's gonna get
the second ball yeah he's dead because
you break through the million penalty
right here
oh this is what i would say oh
all right yeah we played behind that
that that reality is going right there
wow
there was almost enough damage from that
royal uh vanity kill oh okay okay 21 on
one i like need a little bit of girl on
girl
okay
oh my goodness
oh
that's a big deal now that is why i call
it head here my friends he's gonna get
the third bar oh we're about to get oh
[Music]
he did what he can
all right so we finally
mentioned we finally got the first spark
of the game can you make this worth it
oh yeah he's gonna go to like five
meters if he does this correctly
all right into the rocks
i mean this is not gonna kill no no
they're still going to kill yeah number
one maybe to this does it does he need
the second one no he might not
that's the yeah
she lights up
[Laughter]
all right so we got the curler on point
i've never seen obvious play krillin you
know we're very familiar with the player
so yeah yeah i've actually never seen
albums playing filming so this is a
surprise to me but okay i like this he's
keeping the curling screen simple not
going for any of the mix
oh nice oh my goodness try to all right
ty try to play bass vegeta
this might not be the way brother
okay we play a neutral though i respect
it oh okay
some kind i'm kind of like in the full
screen neutral for both guys here
h in there that was a bad match by
obvious
he probably didn't believe in getting
the creator i don't believe oh we
stopped the conversion
oh
that was nice
all right we're gonna toss them right
away
oh yeah no more honest fighters
all right i'm guessing the other side
low hit his toes
oh wow guys he's drunk
he's clearly been drinking before top
eight we don't approve
credit
but
makai's
[Music]
okay
[Music]
all right
all right
no one's getting the points today hey
man if you ask
you'll be actually
if you actually this term is off to a
great start man
we got we got a lag we got a lag out
this is off to a great start this is
what i call a great online tournament
there'll be no points here today
so everyone
so we're going to see how we set this up
issue here guys so everyone please stand
patient we're going to see what happened
there
why the lag the lag out happened why
they synced the way it did
we have no answers we're just
commentators
they could look at our fresh cuts
instead hold up
hold it up yeah yeah looking kind of
fresh i got i got the baby smooth y'all
see
oh let them this
posie though no
i got my hair done got the mushroom got
the magic poop
yo listen yeah the first thing if y'all
ever come to new york i need to see the
barbers bro
don't forget it forget about anything
come to new york barbie especially get a
nice dominican spot
poppy hey the brothers is good too man
this cut was actually done by by the
brother duck shouts to my barber
[Laughter]
i ain't gonna lie i cheated on my barber
with this new cut i feel so bad oh don't
we all yo i feel so bad but it's so
clean
now your cut is definitely clean
i like i like it it looks very nice so
guys we um we're looking like we're
having the technical difficult
difficulties in terms of like the
players
okay okay so the players so we've been
informed the players are still playing
their match though the viewer of us got
uh disconnected instead not the players
so uh y'all just gotta use your
imaginations and uh and fill in the
blanks hold that that's crazy all right
i got three bucks on kite you got three
bucks okay
i got three
[Laughter]
up figure out the three take out the
three rules you know we're honorable man
here we're honorable
you gotta change
i got a five you got a five i gotta
mesio abraham lincoln that's what i got
can i want a friend i want three
[Laughter]
let's get it baby
all right we're going to game two um kai
took the first game um
before it went off it looks like kite
was adjusting
and kind of played the neutral better
they're both choosing full screen
neutral which i like from both they want
to see who really commits here and who's
able to get punished so let's see what
happens here full screen again we got a
conversion though yeah i don't care what
he do he just lost me three thousand
dude
oh my gosh
we need to be professionals here oh yeah
oh that was a very good head here and he
gets a full conversation yeah he's still
into the slide and now he has both
assists he's gonna apply the mix
oh he blocked super dash that's crazy
that was a crazy block definitely online
and
hold the attack
all right it's pc you know it's easy to
attack on that on that in that round so
that was the kite that was the pc okay i
was using that new conversion with a 2g6
mechanic to get more damage
oh but he's not because he's right
which i think players have to actually
go into the lab and see where attack
switches is very appliable here oh yeah
you know
the new tag mechanic this is so good
you need to be using that extra damage
you throw the little short stubby arm
right into the nuts i would have never
seen it coming that was a good tweet
[Laughter]
oh man even though he had a 2h in this
game oh we tried to apply the mix so
here's the thing with krillin right
he technically has small buttons but
doesn't have small buttons yes
they bought they bought five f and five
eight i'm not trying to hear that that
that boy guy he has short buttons but he
has range i don't know if that makes
sense
the smallest in this game be out here
with the big buttons oh stomp on them i
imagine you're talking right away oh
yeah
all right so if you don't mess this up
i'm guessing high think time obviously
definitely smart here though and he
doesn't even get the chance that was
clean
i just want to say i called i just want
to say he might need one loop he knows
you just go for it oh but the toes
yeah
it's going to be close
right here that's actually one hp
that's wild hey by the hair of his chin
chin
you know i'm so cheesy
all right
oh my goodness
was so good
okay
you should get prepper out of here with
the tag move yes yes
that works
spark bait wow
ain't no
good on kite in the last game we didn't
see him sparking he was down both
characters both was one side and he
would lose that spark yeah but that i
think that's also the problem with
especially this match he believes in his
defense so much that he's not willing to
smart and it's kind of it's kind of
fighting him in the beauty right now
wow
that's a convergence
milk chocolate tail she just hit him
let's go
skill
[Music]
all right so i'm already up dude that
means i just got that three more
[Laughter]
all right level three all right if i'm
obvious this is still somewhere right i
will spark it to kill momentum
does it get a chance yeah yeah no in
those situations where the where the mix
is like really hard i'm starting
because if he if he has sparked he would
have had 21 would spark for at least
seven seconds yeah and with two assists
behind him i think he's definitely he
definitely could have like got to get
why is he sparking off these straight
heads
i mean it's hard man but you know here
we go
oh this is just cheap
he's super dash oh my god he didn't
punish her
[Music]
oh my god obviously so many straight
hits
all right
all right
this is simple i don't even go for knock
down here oh yeah level one it's a pizza
okay
we'll find out after
uh i pronounced the journey oh you know
what i'm saying
no question koosiks that's what you
think kate has to make uh
i definitely think he needs to stop
holding that spark into the last
character i think there's situations
especially scrambles where he's not
ready to deal with obvious team because
they're actually really good at covering
scrambles um and i think he's known
yeah he just needs to spark and get out
of this situation entirely like stop
playing his game and just enforce your
own game plan he definitely needs to
start mixing with kid boomer oh my
goodness
but here's the thing though his kibble
hasn't really gotten the chance to
really get the party started now he can
yeah
listen i got to play kite i hate that
kibble i try to kill it as soon as
possible
all right so this is the type of round
kai wants when he wins the point war the
kipper was active that's what we want to
see so this is dangerous remember we've
never seen obviously clifford so this
could be that that you know he's trying
a new character this might be the wrong
place wrong time to do that
let's see how he plays it out here
yeah i definitely thought like piccolo
or maybe even maybe would have been his
option here but
not krillin
with those characters i mean even even
cooler like i would have i wouldn't have
been surprised to see it cooler in this
mix oh my god and he realizes that
obelisk isn't really like actively
playing do you think he's just trying to
avoid him
entirely
he didn't even have to mix him he caught
him in his jumping frames with five
hours so you could tell obviously
actually just holding up back
all right
all right again
oh yeah
[Music]
he's she's never had to vanish yes
but he's gonna have to manage [ __ ]
oh
that was a very good combo that was
optimal yo this all right this is kite
game to win right now all right mother
[ __ ] you can just put that
[Music]
oh my goodness he was about to get mixed
to death
all right
oh no
oh you're done you're done i called it
the minute i saw a kid who gets a plate
i mean you definitely called it all
right i'm up three dollars
oh
i thought he was gonna do it you know oh
okay he was gonna do something else
though i was into it oh my goodness
oh my god this mix oh
my goodness kite
and that's king yeah
my man said what are you trying to mix
me
and she eats them up and he moves on to
one of his finals
that tastes good so acoustics you you
brought into perspective the the the
pats again in france is not over
it's two to three more weeks left
to i need to make this entirely clear
that everyone watching at home will
still compete right
this is the only master event so first
place of course is going to take 200 but
that's not the end of it
you guys still have a chance as long as
your locals have over 64 entries
you can get potentially 100 points for
being at first and i believe couple more
weeks and remember there's seven days in
a week
so
i can make it happen the question is do
y'all want it do
i want to go to paris one day too
acoustics
[Laughter]
oh but so it's so interesting right so
like i don't know if kite is in the
leaderboards but this is a good start to
start your you know start drawing the
leaderboards he's guaranteed 100 points
correct if he gets 30 he gets 100
tonight right yes third guaranteed 100.
so he's guaranteed the top three yeah so
that's really good that's the spot you
want to be in third third is guaranteed
100 seconds guaranteed 150. so
regardless of where he ends up he's he
actually gets within the top five of the
leaderboards i think so i believe top
seven because there's at least five to
six players in the hundred range already
so top seven
if you could get first here
all you need is about like three more
other events with with at least 100
points or something you could
you could make it happen
hey
just as he's talking about kite oh we
even get to talk about this one this one
is very important right
and i just want to point out hikari wins
this he's in the top of the leaderboards
bar you know disregarding coach because
coach likes the gatekeeping stuff
he can he jumps to first if he ends up
with a top three placement so let's see
what happens
oh okay boys beginning
all right
he's getting the first hit all right i
like this this is a new extension that
you can get this season very
[Music]
oh
how are people supposed to understand
this character he's just doing things
listen he's
high oh
yeah you could actually got a 2m starter
from that
stop playing with me bro
all right her car is playing full screen
here as he should
try may try to make pretty much music
command wow
is that that's this is not common i see
mizzy's using b assist by gogeta so it's
it's not common because it's bad right
yeah but if you play a certain style you
can make it work because it's still a dp
okay
not matter oh he drops the combo frames
through matter
[Music]
oh
right now is he going to do it to him b
talk to me
all right same side
yo i am three
[Music]
my man gohan said don't touch my girl
bro i'll fight for my girl
i'll take the charge
all right
hey that's the type of hits akari wants
he wants those two-way shits the bad
badge the bad super dashes makari
doesn't mind taking a round or two
playing that way that's what he likes to
play full screen he likes to actually
weigh it out see if the other opponent
will come in here
all right i like that
just on him oh my goodness but super
dash is the answer to all of life's
problems but
kari was not ready to wait she still has
his wall belt actually so he'll get the
regular boy
it's a level two oh okay
all right all right that's kind of nasty
that's kind of nasty all right guys
all right other side high oh super dash
i think i think he messed up the
super jump ied i think i think he messed
up the macro there yeah definitely
oh yeah so yeah so the way the way music
is playing that vehicle is actually like
good for him and we're gonna get a
re-jump yeah all right nice
he has to get her out yup bringing
vegeta here
oh
there's no mix here bro
no
wow
right
that's actually really good that's
actually really really good all right
other side high again
oh
stop playing with me
yo
are you like reading the future inside
did you see the setup ryan stop playing
with me yo man now what's up does he did
he get to see the pledge before i got to
see the fish this is already transpired
i've played i've played so many 21s bro
i see i play so many twenty ones i see
is good so it's like it's like it helps
me easy in commitment situations right
yeah
he has that layer right behind him
because like in a situation where you
can do like
we have three bars
but golgi is coming in with three and a
quarter let's see what happens only
needs to hit her with super dash if she
dies
oh my goodness oh level three this isn't
a guess for a game though why do you cut
the combo so short he definitely cut it
short if you want to extend it could
have been a guess for game situation
yeah it could have been a guessing game
no he actually needed the damage from
the reject that was gonna be games
oh
oh my goodness
forget my analogy he won the game one
game one
oh what did he prac i think i think he
assumed the command grab was coming and
tried to like screw that suppression he
probably got probably gonna try to check
him
up back
and it caused up back frames oh man the
chickens be getting people killed bro i
told people stop messing them chickens
pluck them out b pluck them up
some chickens on the road or on the
wrong block and you gonna get rocks
that's crazy
so here's the thing i mean what justice
do you tell these two players to do
honestly this was a game round where you
justified literally you just escaped
you know
if i'm gonna be honest i don't i don't
like kakari's team against mizi because
mizzi's team has like a guaranteed way
to get it right because
both vegito and fidel have like very
strong areas for getting in
right so me
is not worried about playing youtube as
much as akari as he is it's like he's
just gonna get in and get his hit
because for 5s he could just for five
minutes he could just be ex larry
oh hold on all right we're jumping into
it ah
oh oh we dropping
oh but we got confirmed oh but we missed
him
that was crazy
yeah look at that he could he could do
the ex legs
or you could do dragon like yeah i mean
we bringing the doubt man get this next
spot let's get this party started you
kill this character it is huge because
18 18 right now one of the benefits of
the season four buffs
okay that was clean
that was chosen
sorcery you saw my man confused wait
what's going
wow don't talk about them bro that was
kind of crazy it needs to spark why do
we bait
oh no no no we're not yeah well we
aren't working all right
[Applause]
we didn't notice that
between
and situations like that are very very
insane we're gonna get mixed here oh
yeah double crease
swallow hood
taste it how's it gonna do them
high same size as same size inside
okay
honestly meiji has to make a decision
here yeah so he has to commit to like
super dash or get it wow
he used he used lariat as a way to cover
the back dash that was actually really
good very very good and now we get going
for free safely as well
oh okay fake safe jumps
all night
oh mix
a lot of the mixed ones
i mean the office on that team is god
like if you really think about it yeah
because like so with the changes to the
golgi there's 2l like that high low is
actually like real now because now it's
a 9 frame 2l that hits low so
so it's actually it's actually good
enough and ambiguous enough for you to
do a high low mix off of the
wreckers
nah nakusa's talk spoke to me can this
come back be possible he has like no
mixed vegeta he has a he has a sword
that's all you got oh
man really got hit by some 5-0
and on up the bastard of damascus
[Music]
all right y'all got here can i get the
ones in chat just with the masters can
you can i get the ones to check
two of you didn't get hit what if you
got hit again all right so it's one one
easy
all right lisa's up on the board man
it's more fun let me let me see those
ones yeah yeah i'll be honest we'll put
1.5 all right
put 1.5
he blocked the initial mix but didn't
block the follow-up that's what it means
that's all right
oh you're right you got it you got it oh
hey you know what's crazy easy actually
won with the team intact too so i think
health management was key here from easy
one thing i'm noticing from akari is
there's no health match he's going one
by one if you actually yeah he's not
he's not he's not doing any switches or
tags that i think are very important to
his team
uh android 18 just really doesn't get to
play against his team mainly
in the past two games
he's actually like he's getting in
quicker than you can set up where and
that's way too important right now
all right but he has to get this party
started you know
remember
is a full-screen monster now wow
so the the other the other problem is
that like
akari it's not reacting to super dad it
means it's like oh word are you not
dealing with super dash oh say less i'll
take credit it's crazy that's some
that's a quality
that's actually very famous
yeah
it's the guy like two h basketball
dashing bad vanishes but i guess right
now i think he just knows where to place
them okay all right this is interesting
this is the first time we've seen hakari
do a change just early and it's a vegeta
oh my man
ah good air there right there and there
it goes and we mentioned the health
management him doing that he got he got
the healthier character out there right
now and now he's just ready
wow
all right
[Music]
all right he's going to stick it with
21. yeah this is this is uh this is
better anyway
21 off oh
right we're saying that arrogant great
nature right now about her card
wow
already happened and we're actually just
looking at the video you know
i just got the replays man he knows
everything
i bet you hakari ones right
how'd you know
we're about to right now right now if
you actually would have done barrier
so the the barrier automatically follows
after after the the key last one with
the android steals so you just have to
press s again but he didn't and look
that's why i don't like that dp that gp
assist has no hits history and what a
super damage to get away from dragon
ball rings the history is pretty low on
that
was high
like it has like hit stop if that makes
sense so so no so it actually doesn't
which is the problem with that dp assist
that's why the other ones are just like
notoriously better because they all they
just wow
all right i'm sorry
[Music]
oh my god the timing on that
the timing of this combo right now
[Music]
exactly when you're a real professional
you call the fight before fighters can
get hurt you're welcome
all right
so honestly
so i'm gonna be real with you this is
something that dismantle x does not want
you don't want hakari in a top three
spot position
with a guarantee 100 points which means
he's guaranteed number one seed right
now in terms of flying out to france
i want it to happen we have to deal with
the evil at home i want the evil to go
overseas
i want them to do it i want to you know
what y'all enjoy it yeah i enjoy it you
have yourself a good time sir you enjoy
that demon y'all haven't i mean that's
my child he's a good kid i promise
no he's not
that's a female
i'm gonna sit here a lot he hasn't as a
demon child playing all right with that
said we got to our winner's side
semifinals
winner final is going to be kite versus
hacart right so we just got to see how
the quarter finals broke down in the
loser's side after those losses that
mesia obelisk um suffered so give it
time we're just going to see how is how
how it updates but right now we're going
to go into
vermour i never get his name right
almost right here here rainier i think
of premiere but then
what's up with the wise man you know
like eyes like that's crazy
i think it's i think it's a mass effect
reference i keep forgetting
we can't mention that oh yeah yeah hold
on
i'll be right in frenchmen
and we got tk breaker and um bag
a bag while we really gotta say that
name on the street let's see that's tk
breezy put some effect on his name
we got bag versus uh tk breaker bag
which is tk breaker
oh android 16 who's been making a
comeback let's see how it goes i'm
curious to see the korean player
oh yeah uh insert coin actually having
um i haven't seen insert coin before so
this is going to be new to me
i like the idea that
and 16 got some buffs
and let me tell you guys vermeer has a
very exciting 16.
really good really good dope with dope
combos i hope you guys love the access
that's coming up let's get it insert
coin versus vermeer vermeer versus
historic coin we gave you wait hold on
hold on hold on is that is that a don't
go on c
don't go on anchor
with wait get you min
oh
is the game plan where i think it is
cool six uh
body switch but guess what he's getting
body right now
oh that was a good super jump right
there that was a pretty good reflect wow
oh my goodness oh oh
okay
i can see how my man wants to imagine
oh yeah oh yeah i can see how my man is
back
so sorry
oh i'm surprised he didn't go for snatch
there
oh
oh that was good oh yes that's him
look if i'm vermour i want to kill get
you you don't want to risk body switch
this is actually a great position for me
he sparks oh yeah
oh vermeer got blocks though welcome to
the block party everyone's invited
uh-huh uh blocks blocks
what a
i think he should have um he needed to
do the the combo tag into vegeta oh my
goodness oh
all right do we have loops just oh
all right so now this is where this is
where the weakness of vermeer's team
comes in
where super dash is going crazy oh oh
and he got to play the game oh
oh no i like that oh
oh no confirmed though
that boy hit him reflect that boy that
boy is he's back he's pretty successful
at it i can't frank
that's why i think like that's another
reason i don't like ramirez too much is
because of how successful it is to
reflect how many levels did you gotta
get is you gotta use three
does it get one
one
one
oh my god so
i think the goal for him i mean if we're
thinking what he's trying to do here the
goal is to get to seven can he get to
seven listen the goal is to win the
match first all right
oh and vermeer just dropping oh my gosh
scramble i'm not gonna lie i would have
actually let these g to die there
because if broly would have completed a
combo i mean he gets to six bars a dog
comes in with seven i want to see
acoustics i'm biased i want to see level
7 go on i want to see if you feel like
that yo these reflections god like mike
that's crazy
he has to eat level three all right he
should be able to get the kill right
here uh actually i
so i haven't had enough data for them
all right so here's the date right this
gopro is at level zero
okay we don't need levels bro
let me find out that he's a viable
level zero anchor gohan this is still
good oh
he committed with jump ass don't do that
brother or knock down
oh
this is insane imagine he makes his
comeback no no no never mind
are we gonna see one of these we're
gonna see one of these cool 16 combos
yeah nice those rejoice
[Music]
uh
all right i'll see if i can come up with
a song so i'm not that crazy hey there
you go i believe in you and game one is
gonna go to vermeer you know it got a
little dicey there supernatural reflect
was kind of like i mean
it was definitely just a nice round man
i can't i i got it i gotta call
experience speed reflexes on deck
and i mean on deck deck
and that boy was like almost a hundred
percent with the reflex
oh i know i could i could see why his
square is still dark red instead of
violence
he's gonna have to answer this coin and
see if he can get game to get the salty
one back and see what happens there his
offense looks pretty strong but he
hasn't had a chance to get it because
vermeer's just like he's been patiently
waiting out these situations and just
blocking the scrambles instead of like
getting caught pressing a button
look at that dragon
um
he hasn't gotten a good time he hasn't
been able to drag himself
you don't need a dragon restaurant you
got super nice that's a much better cool
looking [ __ ]
dancing
let me see the oh oh yeah here comes all
the corner comments
there we go
that even looked right i nearly broke
the game buzzy
yeah my man was like oh
yeah look at
especially if you don't
yeah if you don't cover it
oh my goodness
yeah it's actually pretty meaty and
remembering it's the two parts to
android 16 this is
funny enough if he had finished the
combo that's that's technically a medium
starter so that that he might have been
able to get oh my goodness oh my god
oh he tried to reflect
the one moment vermeer tried to reflect
oh
yo i i ain't got enough t-shirts for all
y'all if y'all want to join the square
motor society
all right it comes down against to this
anchor gohan
at five point three fourths
look man just give me a level five i
want to see here
oh yeah i'll give you a little throw
get mixed by a grapple of beep beep huh
oh
all right here comes one of the cool
combos here we go
oh come on baby how are you dropping oh
all right he dropped that it wasn't a
drop it was there's an american reset
and like always the u.s
superior
all right so verbal moves on to that
fifth spot again um going back to the
current leaderboards right we know
hikari might just finish the night being
in first place no matter the placing
right because you're doing that stopping
running who gets affected here is
dismantle x a guy that was pretty much
at that top spot
to go with france you know he ended up
with ninth i think knife gets you 10
points tonight correct
yes i think it's a 10. uh we could get
the we could get the the point board
again because we can see
so like all right so yeah so gives you
ten points points look he's in that
fifth spot he's guaranteed 45 points 45
45 isn't a bad start that's a good it's
a it's a good number it's a very good
number especially to cut the lead on
this mantlex
45 45 is his third in a 64 event so
that's not bad he still got essentially
like the points he would get for third
but what's important now he would need
to find some first place finishings if
he actually wants to get high enough
yeah and if he wants to really kind of
like guarantee a spot
into france right guaranteed a good a
good lead pretty much which is which
akari is always right right now again
the car is in the top three spot so is
kite both those guys are guaranteed a
hundred points
but the next match we got is bag i will
not say the the following versus tk
baker
is going to fall out of the laundry mat
you know
we have the coins he tried to play the
cabinet and then he ain't no any of the
combos so it's done for him and we want
to thank you for coming out so yeah our
next match back at that verse tk breaker
they're getting ready right now who got
your money up
familiar with both both of them are
definitely like out here type of players
they'll definitely like catch you by
surprise they'll catch you slipping it's
hard to choose um
i think the guy that's most out here is
the guy that's i know that sounds like
so cheesy right but when it comes to
these two players both these guys are
out here man they're very unpredictable
there's a yeah man i i'm curious to see
who wins here
it's interesting the both of those guys
are are on their way to probably get
oh don't mind me i'm just pouring some
water
let me stick to that all right but we're
into the match we got a tk breaker
versus bag amen
so all right
oh
oh
well 6m is unblockable
oh
all right all right okay there we go you
get vegeta out right away
hey let's run with it
we take that we take that
we get the first touch on south
dragon
actually
i don't like it
for the next round of okie but this
works too
all right he didn't go for the reject
there but you know what we keep it safe
oh my goodness
listen you ever had a real man stare at
you can it penetrate you with his eyes
that's what gary does
that sounds very intimidating
yes it does
all right so omega thought was the point
war here
all right you can bring it down
oh my goodness
you know what when you win the point
where you're afford to you'll afford
yourself to have those type of wild
starts so i respected my bag of thought
i actually don't like the level three
here because that's uh that's
technically a calorie starters i don't
coach this is all good maybe maybe he
wants that sparkles
so it ends up paying off he gets that
spark yeah
okay you playing for now drop a couple
of fathers in there
oh reflect on your actions brother
all right
why are y'all playing with you
i feel like everyone's abc right
so there's a link with super jump from
two and five m into into two three six x
but no one's doing that link bro
it's online
wow my goodness that makes kind of
doesn't work out and you did the right
thing there yeah yeah two
oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
with assists but messes it up
oh my god he is oh my oh my goodness
thanks
it's late day we never oh
[Music]
[Music]
part i've never heard i had a remix
because he dropped it
we got the quick remixes
oh my goodness
i like this party
[Music]
tk breaker has his little heart broken
right now i have to lose the game one
he's gonna have to come back the game is
so
well i need to know why my man is
playing css when asus is right there
with 73 frames to confirm i mean it kind
of worked god he got whatever
he tried
i was wondering why he was struggling in
neutral so much i was like whoa
[Laughter]
listen all right i'll be honest
from what i've seen involved from why
i've seen tk breaker has a lot to work
on if he wants to win this match right
has to make better decisions and neutral
uh better assist calls
just better
for him
i want to see what t.k breaker could do
for him are you being a professional no
i'm being serious that faith i've seen
tk breaker get big wins before and get
high places as well oh my goodness
it's a medium star that's a medium
dropper
oh oh my oh my oh wow another medium
started oh he's dead combo attack combo
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
all right legs at the tax rates we want
to get this character out exactly level
three now we do not level three here
exactly run up all right
let them know oh my
you know it's funny he actually he
actually got a better a better combo and
punishment because he did the um
because he's been told for us i mean two
points
yo okay
okay this is my damage and you get like
a little fake knife no you don't oh he
stays in front he stays on okay
look at that you know what's funny you
know what that wouldn't have worked on
the assist
oh
and we gotta call space three bag of
thought is in control right now in this
fight
and my man don't find a better mix than
67 sometimes
okay
there's a third
oh all right tk breaker making some
adjustments here oh hold up
he has vegito compost
okay he's kind of bagging the thought
right now
okay nice little string oh my goodness
as soon as we saw the light we vanished
oh yes
listen the real way to take dragon rush
isn't with the dragon
actually it's actually what vanish or
super damage
all right yo you almost created tk
breakers kind of in the lead right now
[Applause]
oh wait but we got spark we need to pop
it sometimes
thank you
oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh
oh
[Laughter]
oh
thank y'all so much
there's no commitments here
that back i thought try to pretty much
commit
all right
stand by my statement this is what i
like to see who's going to explain
harder
oh my god like this
tk breaker okay
okay
heart is broken
looking at that
that was clearly that was crazy b hey
that was crazy that was crazy all right
with that tk breaker has been broken and
sent out of the tournament as well
they must repair this itty-bitty heart
right now that was that was a set
like you know what's crazy tk breaker
was making the justice but unfortunately
the buck stops here he gets seventh um
at the 45 how many how many points does
he get for seven today cool six speeds
i'm looking forward to that
25 points
right so any point all points matter
yeah everything matters you know so he's
he's at least on the leaderboards right
now
but
baghdad moves along and now he's in that
45 point range and he keep on advancing
so with that being said we're done with
the first round and everything now we're
in
we're in uh the second round second
round of losers we're in the second
round of losers and then we have winners
finals so i think we're gonna go into
the second i can run out of losers i
imagine right
don't worry about that
don't worry about that anyway um
[Laughter]
oh whoa
all right we're going to i think we're
going to our quarterfinals we're going
to have
versus
versus
oh
interesting so we're going to come back
to the casters real quick and
introduce that yeah uh just a few just
to release announcements so we're going
to have burma versus mizi that's a tough
that's a tough set right there that's a
that's going to be a banger oh it's
going be for both players and then we
have baghdad versus obelisk
that's the producers for for the
adjustments yeah yo we got the best
producers in the business shout outs to
so them versus vermour talk to me about
that
that's
that's a real that's always a grand
final set in any online pc tournament
all right
so i'll be honest with you right measly
super dash button will kind of be going
ahead
and vermeer has some very super dashable
assists
uh i think the difference is gonna be
can verma react to me super dashes each
time to get a clean punish because even
though like uh vermour's assists are
weak to super dash he did get hit by a
super dash from insert coins like very
easy like i would say like maybe out one
out of each five hit him but other than
that he was actually like really clean
on blocking after those uh after use of
those assists so it's gonna be
interesting to see what he can bait out
of me i think mizzy actually went with
the captain cage he went with oh
more but more of his more traditional
feet
right let me say i need some mix against
vermeer okay wow
oh wow oh my goodness
oh wow
oh
this place is oh
so but
i i think but they'll actually push them
out of range to get to get that high get
that low
yeah on that situation
he did it you know but the dragon must
have done some meter there so that was
that was good on so that was good on
verve a great combo right there
oh ex lakes oh
oh oh safe side
[Applause]
so here's the thing right so i i have a
very long history of seeing both of
these right when vermeer gets hot he
can't
[Music]
the way he's like super jumping and fast
flowing immediately
this is going to be good damage here
all right
he only has a jump in here
wow
oh six hands oh
[Applause]
spark those are the type of rounds dude
i got i got to do a dragon ball z remix
right
you got to do a dragon ball z remix i
already did one you gotta find one first
of all first of all vegito has no mix
that wasn't mixed everyone in the game
everyone in the game can do cross-ups
i'm tired of hearing that there was some
visual
stimuli that was used against me
that opened him up but it wasn't mixed
no one notices that i think i think he
did sue him into light right that
definitely occurs so he did that
right he did he did the six uh the
assist into two three success into 2m
and measly thought because visually it
looks like jump medium that he was
getting he's going to get overhead and
he got she got low
wow also he goes back to the blue vegeta
he said screw it we're gonna pick we're
gonna pick the cheap stuff
all right listen i'm not going to call
it the cheap stuff compared to kimbu
i mean oh
my god
wow from that range that was god like
listen
16 deserves that oh
oh my that was such a clean job and this
is this is what this is what i was
elaborating on man when vermont gets hot
he gets high it's hard it's hard to turn
to turn off that fire man he's coming
he uses double jumping for me it doesn't
punish oh
oh wow oh my goodness yeah yes i can't
get the meter though nope it's not oh he
got it right afterwards oh nice there's
a five on the dragon rush
all right we're definitely going for the
21 level please we need to we need to
open this man up give us the legendary
can opener swallow him whole
swallow him whole and then while he's
laid out after the deep swallowing mix
it
oh nope i got smarter shorty you can't
catch me wow my man super jumped all the
way oh i will actually wow i would
actually love to see burma get the hit
but the spark is over he has some pretty
good rounds he's dead he's dead and this
might be mirrorless
[Music]
oh my goodness
all right so missy's back in the match
the match actually is even
he could play with that spark a little
more
that wasn't level two spark
oh oh he went mid he has to be wow
let's see what he does here
okay he got as much damage as possible
with that switch and we're going to end
the weather all right so here's what he
gonna do he's gonna vanish and he's
gonna do the same
[Music]
so far in the night vermour has sold his
ability to take dragons his defense has
been really good in that department oh
yeah absolutely he did something
absolutely amazing tonight oh but we're
going to test his defense again let's
see what's up as coos is me gonna do it
to him
[Applause]
oh he's better yeah
all right so
income z broly right four bars
i mean no spark for four bars listen
this is let me break z broly so actually
the game is even though
this this is an even game now it wasn't
even before i like that so now that
forces me wow why'd you run why'd you
run up
you know
he knows easy super dad's going to be
working that's disrespectful i'll get
him easy take chase him oh
all right vermeer not part of the square
by society you don't believe in this
school
oh
he goes into level three i almost got
fired i was about to say well i should
have said
maximum you know what
[Laughter]
can't say that one here can't say that
okay all right this is looking like a
very good match measly making the strong
adjustment uh realizing that cable
wasn't working in his favor and going
for his more neutral heavy team of
gogeta i definitely you do as well yeah
i definitely think he plays neutral with
gogeta better than he does kid boom and
um it just really worked out for him uh
he has a lot more ways to like get in
bigger buttons to work around yeah um
that aren't as like heavily committal in
the air because of course
jump medium is a very committal button
with uh yeah with kid boo but not with
vegito like it's very good it's active
he's been using that as a way to
approach vermeer and it just worked out
so we're gonna see what happens now
let's see if you can actually get the
gogeta to play this round remember that
actually got smoke that's that game
now you get started
oh oh oh my man from here block that
so you're gonna need better mix get this
get this man i can't open it i hang a
lot of mirrors down
at me
oh
my god reward yourself yes
a medium starter
okay oh yeah
oh my gosh
all right oh you're good
yeah
i i see the coast and i'm telling you
man these 60 combos are so cool
that's one does it bring his early i
think he wants to bring him vegeta i
think i would have brought his broly
i actually actually like the vegito uh
yeah
because see the other thing he played
around with with the zebra the assist
because it's a it's a non-supernatural
assist that's really been hidden like
movie and like very awkward timing not
allowing him to like do what he wants
from neutral so i think it's actually
important that he plays uh vegito in
this matchup all right
this is the guard cancel vanish we are
plus there hey it's good
more text on the dragon first oh my
goodness i mean i'll be like all right
now i'm gonna assist my girl no matter
what man
loyalty
are we gonna
which side does she go
uh she's gonna
go to the left side
left side
oh
did me just try to steal my mix good old
hopscotch it's fake it's real to me god
damn it oh nice i like that so he
realized he had just been super dashing
after the initial date
so he was already pre-entered
i thought he was gonna be able to
convert that
go back into steel to get that steel
back you know it works nonetheless gotta
keep on easy
all right so the match-up is not
entirely even right but you know i guess
he's gonna play with a healthier video
here yeah vermeer has a slight health
lead uh but he has to be careful because
he could just go away in one second
yo someone please like he is like eight
finances
that boy is like ninety percent
literally on attacking dragon rushes
hey
we're bad colleges and we don't curse
them once right
[Music]
that's a sign of a good commentary
[Laughter]
oh
i like that he was trying to bait our
reversal options
oh oh that boy was able to upgrade
we're neutral now wow oh two h no two
eggs it didn't come out oh
yo how did he yo that's that that's very
sweet like wow
oh how about your boy oh
anyways back to them
[Laughter]
oh no
i'm just saying we're not starting for
greatness here oh you're right
but mizzy's trying to make sure
he's gonna make sure he is down
for the night it needs to get fifth man
what's up
a dismantle x ah i worry for him i want
to reiterate he got a knife tonight he
actually lost the vermour to get into
the top eight
so verma beat this match likes against
the top eight
remember the lead he was the leader in
the leaderboards hakari's in third
vermer is in the fourth position spot
i'm shaking in my boots right now i
don't think i'm going to friends after
tonight that's how i look at it listen
if i am on this mantle i ain't worried
about that you know why because they
don't have to see me in the future
tournaments regardless and i would just
smoke them that's it if i if i want
first i take first and put them in
second myself it's like like a wise man
once said if you want something done
do it you see it
that was clean exactly
but now we got obelisk versus bag of
thought
all right so this can actually go either
way too so baghetta isn't a good
position i i could see him taking this
the team that he plays is very very
strong you know the combination of jiren
ui with the vegito but the only thing is
that um the vegito a vegeta on point it
doesn't make sense this season just
because
because vegito a is so good
i mean
that's true right but then if you're
trying to have that access at the start
of the match
instead of working to have that access
you know what i mean yeah i i guess that
that's true but so like
i'll be honest i think any character in
the game just automatically gets better
with two assists behind them that's
that's kind of how it works and like um
i think vegito has like a very good
round start as well uh between like 5m
um you could do jump back button you can
even
yeah like there's a lot of things that
he can do that's very good um
so it's it's it's it's his choice
and then the game plan might be all
right i do my combo with vegito get a
knock down and immediately swap into a
new character because
because with the combo with the combo
tag you can do medium legs and then you
can immediately get an air dr with jiren
and you could like run the game from
there but it depends so yeah
and then the case of obelisk what team
does he play what team does he play here
well i think i think keeping kefla in 21
are the best choices i don't think i
don't think krillin was a good choice
room he did get a lot of mileage out of
roxas um
especially in scramble situations yeah
but that's just a switch
which is something i thought is gonna
look to get those type of heads with
jiren i believe he's playing german egg
correct oh yes he's playing gna a which
the eyes he's gonna want those scrambled
situations just how those scramble
situations kind of helped oblivious and
in the kite set right you know he ended
up losing but those oh okay oh now this
is this obvious team i remember it's
definitely obviously he used to wait are
you playing baby brother okay
tonight he's playing getting you with
the ginyu force oh my goodness in other
words he is running you beat this is
scary
man oh yeah oh my goodness oh back at
that guy nicks but no pick up on the
combo wow
i wanna make sure y'all clip that
because oh my goodness it gave him the
anti-air but
that's way too much he should have just
went for dr
and probably get the kill
yeah
oh if not probably through the down
heavy attack um you can so you could so
there's two ways you can end that combo
after the wow
or something yes it's a it's an error
[Music]
[Music]
i'm not gonna lie i like this
combination of saiyan alien steels let's
see how obvious uses it right now
oh he didn't murder though
oh
reflect on your actions brother hold up
he could kill him
that's definitely a body
wait oh that was worth it
i mean it's still enough it still goes
he could have saved so much music
i mean yeah he could he could have built
more meter
he couldn't sleep with the part yeah
he's in quarterfinals and i'm just
commenting in the back
what do we know
i don't know
i mean let me hit the first button
i mean it's obvious
because literally you only have like
probably a second or two a very split
second if not you have like you have
like about uh two flames to hit wanted
to get out of here
okay nice he's gonna get like a little
bit of
springs right there
definitely you should never commit to
five dollars
um oh my goodness
okay oh no baby b baby b is garbage what
are you doing
[Music]
now i've i've fought the french vegitos
i want nothing less than per second
hit them with that pop
with that 5h low that's crazy
[Laughter]
i mean 5 8 slow that'd be choosing
that move kind
that was a big part of the combo oh my
goodness wow oh yeah square buttons baby
jiren the great that is jiren look great
for you oh stare at him again
oh he could he could he could have did
like uh five s tackles and actually
would have killed without using meters
you know you know we want to get the win
wow
oh oh wow
the tip
that was all the tip oh yeah oh my god
oh my god
scramble bamboo baby oh he could drink
that
he's actually could have switched that
that's too easy
i mean i mean off again you know yeah
cause it's because he's he's hitting an
assist
i mean it's not i i mean that's that's
that's gotta be that guy no so so so
remember
hasn't been that before yeah remember so
remember on uh on two one two and four s
with jiren as long as you've recovered
from the move and you're just waiting
you'll get two h because it's a airborne
where he's teleporting to you
i know you could two h um jerry if if he
counts as a cis
there is murders and assists
when you called to get you force give
you force our assist
and you recover he already recovered so
he actually should have two aged him for
that because my man just sat there
and let him just grab a hold of him and
say yo what's up homie let me talk to
you real quick
we learned something new every day shout
outs to the boy acoustics for that great
tech technology knowledge that was crazy
technology knowledge technology i
oh we got he went back to kai and
krillin
and let's see maybe this could work
possibly
just because he won't build up i don't
think he'll build a love mirror to kill
oh no no he definitely can't go for me
but yes nice this time he just did the
dragon like this is good
nice
i like that little adjustment off the
empty venus combo right and now he's
building a lot of meter too
that
look at that oh yeah and you can count
so that's the other thing jiren can't
count together
that's why that's why it's important for
you to do it
wait that was a happy birthday he got a
hit
all right you definitely need to get
curled out of here
and go to that 21 mix yeah i'd like to
see
we swallowed aliens too let's go oh my
goodness it don't matter
sigourney weaver you know
he did not just dash out of the mix okay
if the mix isn't done properly you can
just dash out
but we just say he's going to screw it
and this and this time we're gonna at
least reflect or we're gonna dash can we
hope
i don't i will never choose reflect i
don't want to get bodied
i'll move i'll hit a button i'll just
say but i will reflect
[Music]
[Music]
the super dash is the guaranteed 2h
right what swords
yeah yeah
no no no you can't you can't super uh
but it's like it's dependent on blocks
done every single time so like if you're
in the air you wouldn't be able to do it
if you're on the ground uh possibly
oh my god that's so unfortunate so
so back attack came in with a roll
attack and i saw obviously 21 doing the
backflip motion but it didn't come out
with wow
wow okay listen i've seen that the world
wouldn't happen it's very good
god like man awareness is on point
again that was good that was very good
that's a that's a strong man penetrating
you with his weight brother
in other words that that is how you play
behind assists guys that was really good
on baggage out there i mean i saw you
from across the board and say oh
what's good
can you get the conversion though i
think you should have super that's not
convert yeah you definitely could 73
frames you can supernaturally convert 73
frames oh you're dead
okay
yo
man
so the interesting thing right now about
the about the way top four is looking
the guys that were in top a winner's
side
oh
okay
wow
very tasty
very tasty
interesting i wonder how that disconnect
happened you know
producers
losers
but nonetheless so the interesting fact
right um the two guys that were in
taipei one
argus
that we're in people inside and ended up
going to losers are at the bracket they
actually finished in fifth that being
meezy
and obelisk right their run ends here
and now you got baghetta in top four
vermeer and software loser size and now
we're going to win this finals which is
kite versus sakari
so
i could give you the historical facts
give me the historical facts
historically
hakari was this almost every time
i'm talking long set short set
you know kite is a very strong player
but if there's someone that
kind of could make kite look free it's
this young man akari 16 years old at a
long island
shout out to him
so this this is gonna be interesting
three first two three
we hope that kite can bring his a game
he has to bring the same game this is
huge
you win here you're guaranteed second
guess what happens if you get second
150 points you're in the 150 to 200
point running and that's what you want
you can you can smell the baguettes from
second place
and trust me i had that breakfast oh you
gonna be eating good
man let's see what happens this set is
definitely important
guy's about to get the party started
[Music]
people not believing in their super dash
is like hitting oh my goodness that's
another medium starter all right we're
going to see some a little bit of
optimization there by akari
he kind of ended the combo short or was
it was the damage yeah no this this is
great damage and it gives you good it
gives you good setup that's that's the
most important thing especially against
like a player like kite you want to you
want to end like a good knock down on
your combo that was such an amazing air
there and he he knew it was going the
legs were going to cross out but he
super jumped to make sure that his
character would turn around to punish
him that was really good
yeah so so kite's also really good at
like super jumping um to get certain
conversions or to pick up good air to
air which is important with his team
because they don't besides 21 they don't
have like the biggest of jump normals so
it's like they have to get those pickups
every time they can after that oh he's
staying up
wow
my man tried to reflect and got
oh
ah man
i totally understand it man
character tricks
tricks are for french
oh
hey this is looking like it's for the
americans too all right
oh
get the blue light back on vegeta uh mix
with 21. uh you can still get a high low
here
yes
oh my god that was like that was
actually a really good um a really good
uh
guard cancer right here has he already
committed to the medium
he went low here all right kaiser is
still strong
yep
look oh barrier okay
nice oh
wow what a combo i was about to say when
that headstock cut yeah yeah it
definitely was gonna stop story
all right yeah
mind you that's a broly level key blast
now so it's definitely so against the
mortals if a z broly
i mean everyone just dies to that
literally yes yeah
all right we got the results
[Music]
all right they needed
a little bit wow
that five actually covered the wrong
side that was pretty good
okay
good patience
trying to get in no matter the car
back down
yo look how even this match is guys we
are 150 seconds in oh yeah these guys
are playing their hearts out right now
oh yeah this is this sweaty match time i
like the oh oh just as i say that
that's just a mechanic oh he's not dead
though level one into i think
wait hold on
boy hold up grab
no
he tried that he was actually dead
he was dead but the combo the scaling
was way too high that's why he tried to
exit oh that was good bringing 21. i'm
bringing 18. he's definitely dead here
now i'll tell you that much godly my
goodness
yeah over here oh i know costumes are
somewhere in the chat and smiling
[Music]
barrier is the worst assist in the game
you gotta stop getting beat up by nature
that's what makes you think it's tough
fight
[Laughter]
all right oh
look at that the french characters back
on the screen thank you thank you for
having me commenting
this is looking like it's going to be
one of those banger sets
so the players have been like paying
incredibly patiently so this is
that was amazing is he gonna bring 21.
oh
whoa oh my god
[Music]
one mix to mix them all oh
yo this round is insane the momentum is
literally going back and forth here guys
this is still quite possible for akari
he needs to get like one type
here
since he already vanished
yep
all right
he has to be he has to be mindful of the
commitments because he he actually can't
commit tonight right now because he has
no meter
so throwing those three key blasters is
very dangerous right now
what he's not doing now he can do it
because he has a meter and there you go
oh my god don't forget guys back dash is
minus 15. so if you chase it down and do
five dollars
you're welcome
wow all right
yeah
yeah we might as well we might have to
put on a big boy pants for this set it's
looking like it's gonna be a doozy that
was a one guys
it was amazing i'll be honest i don't
like the back dash against vegito
because of how many options he has to um
to cover back dash he has five m he has
five m to n two l e ex legs 5l
like this there's really there's really
nothing you should have done
i don't i don't think he should have
back dash in the air and then if you
choose uptech
to chase yeah but even then uptake is
probably like your safest option
oh yeah uh-huh call my brother to play
neutral for me
i respect that time oh yeah barry give
me some meter brother we got half a bar
right there and we got order before that
wow wow
i'm actually jumping in right now he has
no assists oh no i'm not jumping in
there
you jumping on 18 and her brother's
barrier is accidentally did you die it's
the worst that's the worst feeling in
the world i mean we jump in and bait
that right
so like so if she does the air barrier
it's not really reversible you have to
wait for him to like mess up
you have to wait for him to mess up and
do like ground barrier or if you want
you can punish with supers
people don't do that yet but we're gonna
people are gonna start learning to do
that soon because you're gonna have to
all right that's a true string in jail's
it's like vegeta looks like he needs
control but he's actually in control the
whole time all right we got mix oh we
got mints this is what we got
dude is this one bar
yeah
no that's what i would say
bro i can't do math bro
hey that's where that the mathematician
comes
in
oh my goodness
air
what shakari has shown so far in the
night how strong he is in that
department yep oh number three we gotta
mix we're pop i found
uh if i'm not mistaken i believe android
21 is the mother of android 16 that's
the lord
oh but then this is like a clone android
with margin dna so that's technically a
problem
that means dr jerome was ahead of wow
that was a guy like twitch
that means he was ahead
wow
instead that was really really good yep
the car is playing really well right now
okay he's actually getting caught up in
his office
oh oh
all right but kaiser a little bit of
offense on his own
that's that's the real mix right you
just when you know your opponent is good
you patiently wait and then you get your
cross up as late as possible
hit this
oh
my that is one of the hardest problems
to do online so i'm not going to say i'm
not going to say anything but i'm going
to say one thing right yeah nitro would
have finished back up
now
it's a 50 50 man to go in this setting
right it's hard to go for that combo it
is the optimal route but it's guys
all right hit it with the deep three
feet
oh my gosh so right now jakarta has to
guess the game here
okay
oh
oh my god he reflected there oh yeah
stop oh
he's dead he's done
he has to go for the air level three
though
that's it
oh my god atari
yeah don't worry that's only good too
remember this is winners finals type can
make one last adjustment this is last
chance but here's the they know kite has
to bring it back three games in a row
and the way both of them are playing
it's going either way right now that was
again game two last character last
almost last touch
this
okay could win the next two games cause
i'm really enjoying this set i really am
shout out to both for carrying shots to
both you can tell
yeah both players are playing amazingly
well they're playing like they really
want to hear yeah but i'm about to smoke
him again so uh let's go with this next
match oh my god you're horrible
you're absolutely horrible strange
listen listen the way i close it how i
seize it a real a real professional
and sometimes blunt i'll be honest i
mean kite
is running out of air to fly on right
now that kite is going down bro
kaye is going down bars and delivery
bars and delivery
[Laughter]
no but i'm really excited i'm really
happy to see both of these guys playing
really good like this um
i want to see i want i want to see this
go to game five you know that card is
more work of us
i don't require work of us
we're so good
we're commentators and we see that it
might be a frio
we'll take those we're happy with that
listen if i see a frio
somebody get roasted right now
kite know i love them but he's he's
looking like roasted pig on the barbecue
the way hikari getting into him right
now one thing right um it's really hard
to roast kite like they're he's playing
amazing it's just a case of don't hurt
any better play better of course you
could of course you're definitely right
you could definitely play better because
if i ignore how bad i am it's never
impossible to roast other people who are
better than me it just works out hey
here's the thing right at the end of the
day the final score is gonna say three
yo you know
how do you tell someone yo it was close
you can't you can't you can't just say
yeah it's 3-0 but it was close we let
that happen to me the final score speaks
value so right now
kai has to avoid that because this has
been a good first two games
all right let's see what happens here
barrier round start with half a bar
that was a godlike conversion by the way
the jump cancelled right off the bottom
right there really good
i like that he tried to he tried to
delay something
baby yo he got hit by a raw gumball oh
my goodness
he has an answer to that now
[Music]
keep up the pressure yeah don't let
don't let him out
he might kill you
oh my god that worked yo
that was godlike sometimes you gotta
sneak it in
good job
i i've lost the words that was just so
amazing about hikari oh yeah and that's
that's an anti-reflection anytime he
goes in from like one normal
oh okay you you all that type of time
oh you hold that sound job
oh
he could actually kill with the two bars
he could have killed the two bars but he
was trying to get the assist to make it
a one bar kill that's not the most
possible as you should but you know what
it's it's game point
was going to get you to consider the
grip
oh my god height
if there was ever a town you had to be
garlic for 21.
now is the time because this hell this
comeback
is looking very steep
well
mothership you guys need to start with
this one
i want to believe it i want to believe
in kite listen listen
you know i don't be i don't believe in i
was told at a young age that santa was a
real so i don't believe in these things
all right there's no come back santa's
fake no
and kite's gonna lose his three oh i'm
sorry
israel oh
he is real oh okay me ain't got chimneys
in the hood posey house again bro
fire escape what's your thing
we got nothing but fires
my fire escape lock my mom told me never
leave that joint open bro
that was good
[Laughter]
she was right
[Laughter]
all right i believe in kite
hey hold on wait hold up are we taking
the receipt is this murphy
my god
unfortunately that's one bar left
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was him i was just ex and throw all
those properties away man
these are actually good properties
because he could read a super dash with
the with the barrier and punish it oh my
goodness
oh that trait was about to be insane yo
if i was kite i would cry but luckily
it's not the case here drop no mas even
though you're not
that was that wasn't even the best one
[Laughter]
that was crazy
y'all tired of this bro
i'm tired of this long long game bro
time to hit it
so it asked me
that's how you lose bro yeah okay he
really did it to him
i lost i lost my tongue
that was insane sometimes the most
optimal move is the move your opponent
never expects
that's that's quite literally what
happened there yo
that is literally the definition of
anticlimactic
that was
that was right i was ready for kite to
get like one more combo for it to be
real sweaty my man got bumped as well i
was expecting a very dramatic ending
before was me wrong no
boy were we wrong
whoops
looks like i made a mistake
i'm sorry
oh oh oh
that's going to drop kite to losers
right so he still has a chance to get to
top three
uh
he can still he can still make the
comeback possibly and even get first
right he's running still has a minimum
of at least uh 100 points to his name
which is really good right
but our net our next match is gonna be
our losers semi-finals
and it's going to be let's get that
let's get that list here again um bag of
thought versus vermour
all right no mercedes
dog get this far bro what's wrong with
y'all people
hey
professionalism he's been playing pretty
good man
he shows real good
doing the job here okay i'm doing my job
has been playing real good let's give
the boy some you know let's give the boy
the applause yeah
yeah he played very strong guys i like
the way um he actually was able to use
his team
the assets that his team bring right
listen the only reason the only reason i
bag on bag of thought is because we did
a team tournament together and he ain't
carry carrying the victory so i'll never
let him i'll never let him live it down
you got to hold that so here we go we
got but he we got game time burma demon
time verma i'mma give him the title just
for tonight i don't give it to everybody
okay i will give it to everybody he is
on demo time
vermeer has actually been doing od today
amazing
the guy literally is averaging a 93
percentage dragon rush tech ring that
boy is taking some dragon brushes today
too mind you he's actually taking dragon
rush he's not he's not like super
dashing it or driving
he's attacking it he's like he's old
[Applause]
yo we was dead just crazy the hell had
this guy
[Music]
[Music]
so
that that works from dragon rush when
you have characters that have long um
specials like that you can you can get
the dragon rush into into the into that
move with goku but they have to be they
have to be closer to the corner i know
because it works with uh
with rotate as well
okay vanish here
oh oh my flex on your actions brother
73 frames instead of hitting uh 73 bro
if you can't convert off a vegito a i
actually don't think fighting is good
for you
hey man
70s posey 73 frames is one
and one sixth of all of a second
exactly you got it
all right so now verma actually used his
arc already
so
oh that's a medium starter i was just
back without letting him know that he's
he's yeah he has very good momentum
right now and he's in the lead oh my
goodness your helmet
oh my oh
that was hard
oh my goodness
that was that was fire
oh my god
yeah i'm fighting myself someone said
just go see you right now
do it
he said knock down into active legs
slow oh now hold up commentary oh my
goodness oh that's not dropping that
combo he really needs to not drop
anything right now oh 67 is unblockable
though it doesn't doesn't matter how
good the detail is
all right oh look at this combo okay
back at that showing some combos here
okay
did we level three no no you don't level
three
the only time you were level three if
you were taking him back mid-screen you
should have like
[Applause]
oh
no
oh
so he gets to bring in right goku
yep
uh he could have he could have also just
combo tagged from the um
from the ex graph because when you do ex
grab you can um when you do the the
combo tag it actually allows you to
choose a kind of one you can even get a
rejoice oh my goodness oh
okay
stop
oh and this one has this this uh this
other one has more frame advantage
oh my god oh my oh my we are swinging
and detect the tech is back i won't
bring up tech support
oh back at that no
ah
i've noticed that when the when the
going gets tough or when the scramble
gets scrambled
when the going gets tough we mask square
brothers yeah that i see but back attack
can still do this
this has to be decisive here
any bases
can't get hit like this my man
all right can i get the conversion there
oh wow
so he tried the ex grab change to catch
the banana oh my god
oh
[Music]
oh my god we're getting fired
i don't know what you're talking about
he's going north for freedom he was
holding north
oh my god oh my goodness
oh my god that was god like though
all right and game one is going to go to
vermeer he's looking absolutely clean
right now
uh i'll be real with you if i'm over
here i'm a little nervous right it's it
was definitely a little a little more
closer for comfort as i ex than i
expected yeah back at that is definitely
getting in there man and he's gang
he's not taking back at those dragon
rushes that's why i'm a little you know
a little weary i'm a little scared so
when someone that you expect to hit you
suddenly starts grabbing you you get
confused it's like something
yeah so let's say you you go into the
ring for like a roll with a with a
wrestler and then he started boxing you
you would get confused right now
exactly so i think that's exactly what's
happening in this match up here my man
back inside suddenly pulling out the
wrestling man
right i actually i actually like the
advantage just because he wants to get
the side switch get him back in the
corner you know jerry's pressure in the
corner is something serious oh yes
absolutely uh-huh oh oh yeah two hours
i don't know what he's waiting for
oh
that's a medium starter let's get
damaged too
he definitely from the bronx bro he'd be
working on the upper body only yeah
y'all know what i'm talking about you
jumping them up b
oh
wow that was an amazing point how's that
amazing
oh
[Music]
but those situations where he doesn't
know the immediate answer he makes bad
choices and it's hurting him he's even
choosing the proper time to reflect
right but i think his author reflects
he's relying so much on the power
oh my god
wow
hold up that was some legs though
[Music]
that's so smart
i would actually run up dragon once here
my man for me oh i would have ran him
grab i wouldn't let him know oh
[Music]
okay okay it worked out it worked out
right but i was really scared that was
good wasn't gonna work out oh yeah
absolutely absolutely all right hold on
premiere down to his last two characters
he was in this situation before he still
made the comeback
but the thing is he's the difference
right he lost as he broly
[Music]
all right i was switching to jiren leg
jiren dragon rush very nice all right
into the corner safe jump oh my goodness
oh baby
oh wait hold up oh no combo why did he
oh no come on we have seven jackpot
wait the seven dragon balls is on the
screen right now
oh my god he probably didn't notice
dude
he wished
he didn't notice oh
how did we get seven dragon balls just
quick by the way
[Music]
and i think we bring in vegito here yep
the healthiest character on the team
right now and we play full screen we
lame it out vermer has to come in oh
yeah oh look at those seven dragons
he ran up on him playful
oh yeah
please don't don't use your meter come
on you got the dragon ball i know you
want to kill him but think about the
dragon balls
no
oh wait he has four
yeah no remember he has a level four
though yeah he has level four so he had
a service policy good enough burma right
there
actually
he doesn't have to do much you know
straight to super he's doing a lot all
right
that wasn't a lot at all look man i get
scared i i just want to go to the next
round that's all it is with me okay
brother okay well listen i just we're
not going to the next round yet remember
this is three out of five
this is two out of two out of three
three out of five top four
this is losing seven wait is this a rule
top four is three out of five
oh yeah i'm getting five how do you know
that
producer can you confirm that this is
the two out of three set is it
is a three out of five
oh what
i'ma just drink my water
it looks like i made a mistake oh my
goodness hi i'm sorry
how you deeply sorry oh my goodness
that was crazy
all right so it's 1-1
right now
i got mixed
i'm not gonna say anything i'm gonna say
this is why i opened up uh the stream
guys
so someone read all the slides and it
wasn't posing
that was a good hit right there
so when the producer can you probably
get a hold of it maybe we have to read
after the match
but ooh okay
but there's a good combo by vermont
right here
all right i'll toss them in the middle
oh
right that's amendments oh wow wow
could have jailed them all
listen 2l is the answer to it
it's actually an answer
i mean it has to be close range though
but if it's within a distance to our
losers i've seen movies
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the coach
we'll be having the best movies
all right nice
for me getting the combo
awesome
now you gonna
oh yeah you got five l twice in one
combo this joined by the scale he better
end this as quickly as possible
yep all right
i like that nice and concise waistline
and then with sister three as well yeah
he could do level three and then he
could uh vanish right after this yep
oh my god
that was god like they couldn't get the
punish
oh we oh
great
oh my god this might be enough
[Music]
all right so this just got a little bit
even but burma does have more resources
more meter more spark wow oh my goodness
but someone got more friends to convert
and it's clearly a bag of thought right
now
oh
yeah yo listen 5m is a button bro oh my
gosh
oh no wow that's an airtight air
oh yeah
oh yeah well welcome to the command
grappler central brother
oh yeah no you get frame advantage look
it's oh
that's that
level one is kind of shafty now
i like i i just like the visual of it it
looks nice
[Music]
oh
oh yes
he's not gonna kill but he should uh
definitely just knock down get the level
three right here
he has a bar that i have to play with
all right
if you're really real
walk up grappling that's why we're here
i just i just know i know these pieces
i just know these people
my reason i've been playing i've been
playing a lot of more mobas recently
my read game is getting crazy
[Laughter]
i was playing
i was clean you got it all right so
burma goes up 2-1
and wow and it looked like bhagat
thought was in the fight but then like
rumors just as soon as he got momentum
he ran with it and it went and he ran
far with it and then every time back i
thought try to get back into the match
it was oh it almost felt like it was too
late yeah but he was he was there but
right now baghdad got to fight for his
life right now
he's up 2-1
all right and they just switch positions
again
[Music]
oh yeah fast switch mix again let's go
all right um producer when you get a
chance i guess you'll switch the names i
don't know why this is happening i don't
think trying to mix
listen if you so no because i thought if
you lose you can change you can change
what size you own and clearly
vagabond did that to get the mix over
vermeer
it is working right now look at this
oh trap yo
wow wow that's a medium starter too
[Music]
he got so much more damage he kind of so
short
wow that was a very good empty batter
oh oh oh
oh yeah throw right into the corner
we actually actually don't like this i
think i think you should throw into into
rolly
[Music]
two bars it's a change
right
so yeah remains looking good oh what the
spark
oh
oh oh
you feel that you feel the weight
between those two oh he was hitting
off the ground
[Laughter]
oh my goodness this this is
wow
that's a sick that's a six frame inside
here that has a low
on attached to it as well
wow
[Music]
he was a problem there
he should have known better not to just
jump yeah yeah so
there's a lot of times when he's driving
or doing an air motion against 16 it's
not going to work
my man be like no
don't do it all right he's coming to
level 3
i actually would have vanished to see if
you could kept them in the corner at
least near the corner no no this is
better because mid-screen if he vanishes
he could get uh um he could get better
mix
oh he didn't oh wow
he did it way too slowly as well uh
cause you could get medium five out from
that but you gotta do that the frame
after the level three ends so instead
you should have just went for advantage
and then you could do for some id
wow just like that that that was pretty
the the moment the tide changed very
quickly
river ended up taking 3-1
after that game two that i was like whoa
hold up this this is looking a lot
closer than i thought
it he ended up taking it 3-1 man vermer
isn't top three dismantle x
uh start sweating bullets buddy
because the two guys didn't want to kind
of catch up
kind of caught up tonight
listen if you're a real warrior you're
not worried about these people catching
up you welcome them catching up so you
can body them yourself
exactly
what why let why like why let someone
else take you out of tournament i want
to take you out
oh i want anyone else to want you i want
you
hey man i just want to reiterate vermin
was the one that took this mantlex i had
the brackets against top eight and now
he is top three guaranteed 100 points
let's see if he can jump into that 150
to hundred point if we if he can be kite
right here and get the 150 hey mayhem
and akari are eating tonight good
because both of them are at least
guaranteed 150 and one of them is going
to go home with 200.
okay that's nothing like money right
that's nothing like money
right now and carrie until you realize
you got homework you need to be doing
instead of playing the grand finals
um
so so right now we got kite versus the
cars verma so here's the thing right
um i've seen this is um knowing the
player
i've seen a lot of times where kite
gets to that windows final spot right
but then
falls to losers when it doesn't work out
yeah and i kind of see him usually
struggling to get back into that mode
that got him to where his finals right
you want to see him keep deposits just
be stay positive and just
get in there and you know just get back
at the fight i don't want to see him
defeated
this is tough though he's going up
against a gained vermour of vermeer
vermer i'm gonna call him vermour he's
going up he's going up against a game
rumor and look man just look at that
just look at that scorecard guys first
second and third those three guys are at
least going home with a hundred and
better
but who's the one that's gonna stay at a
hundred who's gonna advance to that 150
tier it's coming down to kite versus
vermin who's gonna see hikari in grand
finals let's be who goes home with that
big 200 cousins i want to see this i
don't want to talk oh perfect perfect
savage i want to see darkness
what's he darkness when
i want to see the chops i want to see
action baby we got kite versus vermin
let's get it popping baby
[Laughter]
all right so right now we got kite
where's all
kate is already getting mixed that's
what i want to see but let's let's see
this is this first touch let's see how
oh
okay that's interesting oh
all right
hold on i get it
get the size
[Music]
uh through the penalty it's actually
really good
nice and that's such a good awareness
remember guys ex move forward if you
guard cancer on the initial hit you will
not
all right that's this is
honestly if we've been paying attention
to this
this movement at the speed of sound
we play a real dragon ball and let me
tell you slide man have you been paying
attention to both guys tonight they
haven't been sparking first like first
touch first character they both sparked
first characters i think they're
realizing the importance of this set
that was that was so cheap i'm not my
man my man
oh that's so unfortunate oh
[Applause]
yeah it looked it looked like 2s that
was interesting that means he's been
taking with two ass
oh no he wasn't ready to age
he ended up jumping there instead
oh my god
okay all right
my man my man kite is getting is getting
off the the the protagonist right now oh
yeah you're done
with it so proud of that mix oh my gosh
that's the faulty thing
he said come out let me show you mastery
let me show you
that that photo is so amazing is
literally one of the best images that oh
whoa
oh my tricks
oh you could say it was tricks baby all
right my man said if i move as fast as
possible
right to my mix
i like this right here yep yeah
let the ball drop give him a present
all right
oh the gift of bread
oh my god the lure no i was going to
mention that he burmer needs broly to
get the pretty much control this match
down and just what are we doing with
vegeta supporting the back man
oh my god he's getting hit
[Music]
wow just like that that big man just
came to the screen and said hey listen
if a man is big as broly holla at you
right
sometimes you just gotta hold that right
he highlights you would be like yo
what's up
i'm not gonna like kite is fighting
right now level oh
okay nice
level three
i almost said the dark words that should
not be spoken i almost said what's the
mix oh no
something to say different
sounds
sounds to talk never sleep they called
us out for being lazy
bro
i was taught when i was
that oh to be a fat figure kite please
tell me that was a bad finger you're
freaking freaked out
why did that happen free that was the
fact no way
oh my god i don't even know what to say
after that it's just oh i know what to
say you gotta hold that we take those
that's what you say we take those we
take those
so i want to see darkness i want to see
darkness the darkest timeline is kite
losing
ninja hoodie
huh
but nonetheless
oh my god kate i'm so sorry
oh my my man looking at his controller
yo that that's that's a hard that you
might lose a set after that i don't want
to encourage that but
that is
oh
i hate no no he's angry now that was an
angry super dash
[Laughter]
please
you saw the 12 disappear
you know
kind of like the second time that's
happened wait
what where's vermeer tekken with because
it's looking like down something right
yeah he's down taking with two up
no i mean what is he taking dragon
wrestling though too well
oh we got to see the sparky combo
you saw the the
sparking drops oh she almost converted
oh oh my goodness wow all right burberry
remember it's kind of just violence oh
my goodness they're both choosing
violence
oh wow
don't confirm
that
you're just doing so violent today
oh yeah that's a nice dragon rushing
okay that's visual mix you saw the
assist so you don't press a button and
then you still get hit by dragon but
it's the worst oh you died he actually
got here yeah
guys
what do you think is that going to be
close here
oh [ __ ]
oh wow
so he did 67 because he was hoping it
would it would be the timing and wake up
reflect oh no unfortunately
i played that situation more he wasted
both assists they didn't get to utilize
any of them verma did great evasiveness
there it's like that he loses 21. and
again
these are cisco's my kite is starting to
be it starts to
look pretty glaring
wow
broly he really just like
literally
[Music]
i think i think we're done here
all right
all right
hey man that was a brave super dash
three level three i mean kate has the
super dashing each one of these
so is it is it brave or is it
stubbornness right i don't think dragon
versus the way because he's been taking
drag races all day
all right i did it again just to let you
know
oh my goodness
all right all right we got pressure oh
oh yeah
you take those oh yeah ex legs the
french specialty
oh my goodness all right all right good
good good luck he got he got straight
there but you know remember can't do
anything about it
wow
trades we actually take those trades i
definitely do over here
i have to be careful with supernatural
vermour while he's in the air
because at the end of the day if ever
blocks the super dash that command grab
is going to be followed up quickly
assuredly oh
the blocks
oh welcome to the blood party hold up
hold up we still blocking
oh
okay okay kite is fighting he's not
going down with a fight right now
all kite you know what
you gotta go down swinging man
i believe in kite all right
but right now berber is kind of wild
he's playing really really good
i know man um close to that
staying hydrated
staying hydrated it's not easy guys it's
not easy but we appreciate you guys
supporting coming to the stream checking
out this great top eight online action
for the bandai te kaichi world masters
challenge all right we appreciate you
guys supporting the east coast most
importantly i hope you guys have been
enjoying the matches this is the losing
finals right now we got vermour up 2-0
against kite
does the buck stop here for kite
acoustics does the buck stop here you
want you want the professional opinion
or the honest opinion professional i
want to keep the job first
professionally
uh
honestly honestly he's been done after
game one
oh man because that loss was so tough
right exactly
tough losses when they affect players
like mentally especially players who
like
a lot of that gameplay you can tell is
based off of how they're doing
emotionally and it just happens
it's hard to shake those type of losses
especially
when a fat finger really leaves to kill
i mean we really take that
wow he really take that
my you it was hidden by the android 21
assistant you still take that that's
crazy oh well that was a very weird
all right we're gonna get as much damage
as possible
oh we got level two we can move okay all
right and i noticed i just noticed the
switch where kaido is running
instead of uh
no he's been running for the whole time
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
yo i've actually never seen vermeer wake
up right now
we'll be safe this time
wow he reflected the mix and i think
kate actually did the right decision he
just went in there with one button
see what verma is going to do he chose
reflex but wasn't ready to punch that
wrong attack oh my god can you get the
third bar
yeah oh
okay oh man it was gonna make it very
close let's see
21 pick up the black wow
wow 0.5 hp
one more quite literally
okay wow wow hopefully you saved
something
the the disc assist when vegeta actually
hit him and stopped the raw attack from
running into two
that's crazy oh that's a fortune for
kite though
all right
you can reflect there um but i need to
find a way to start putting these
reflects oh i'm good i'm gonna be real
with you we're kind of ignoring the fact
that kate is in the lead right now
[Laughter]
he died he died
yeah he died oh my god
oh
no no no what he needed to do so you do
vegito level one while broly uh level
one is happening and then you can do
command grab afterwards he didn't do
that
yeah he messed up he would have gotten
the extra damage to kill he's looking
like vermeer matt lacks he man
exactly oh
wow look at that look at this
i wish i could teach all these kids wow
all right it always sucks again to lose
the character that way
the straight way oh no
that was not a good keep last place
okay
oh my god oh yeah
oh yeah he was in the fight
shoot him up chicago styles
oh yeah
yo murmur is one character away from
gang it's a second place
oh okay all right
we're done here
thank you for letting me finish the
sentence before you
abruptly ended the
end of the set
yo
this is crazy
uh i understand kate i understand have a
good night
having a name this level of power was
created to destroy goku
oh
though all right man with that kite is
out of the bracket he ends up with dirt
ends up with a hundred points for the
night okay it's not bad that's not bad
that's a smart he would have to commit
to some more tournaments if he still if
he wants to stay in the running but this
is a good head start because uh
go ahead go ahead no because uh cause a
hundred is is a good head start
because it's essentially oh i won a 64
million bracket so if he can win other
64 man brackets you can do it remember
seven days in a week tournaments are
happening every day
don't forget guys you guys can still
apply on smash gg to make your online uh
event a tenkaichi event right so it's
still possible for players to still get
points as long as people in the
community are still providing uh
tournaments on both pc and ps4 for
people to still enter so don't give up
this is not the time this is just the
beginning this is this is like so this
is like someone gave you a zenkai boost
right now
right if you were in this event but this
is not the end don't keep training
so here's the here's the thing though
cool six i will say that
if the if two out of the top three
players in the leaderboards wasn't first
and second place tonight
what is going on
they switched to quick no i was gonna do
this darkness
so that's the thing that's the thing
it might yeah they're already top three
they're already looking like a sewer to
go to france
you don't want these two guys to be the
top two seeds in a tournament like this
not with 200 points at 150 points online
all
uh i call it jerome's angels that's the
yesterday
that's a pretty good if you know you
know that's a good name
oh my goodness oh my goodness i don't
think today was the time to play
jerome's angels together i don't think
it was i think he should go back to the
so here's the thing right her car beat
burberry as the in the city of mayhem
thousands mom
he actually sent him a loser so
who knows maybe burma got a little you
know a little saw him he wants to get
him back for that set
but or he just wants those 200 points
man let's see wow
yep so that's that's a good os to deal
with like uh dragon rush as well oh but
he misses the conversion
[Music]
oh
he thought he was going to do key blast
so he tried to super dash it but he did
the physical hit instead because he even
that is a mix funny enough
i wish market we
[Music]
oh you're dead you're done yo you're
done you're done yo it's berber he's
kind of running away with game one right
now
akari's gonna have to work really hard
to make this comeback
because his team is fully healthy but
then again he got 21 with spark a close
seven bars
that is that that's practically seven oh
no
it's clicked but no conversion right
there
oh wow wow
my mission 202 else
hop over and say hi that's crazy i'm hit
you with tweets right now
and we're about to get mixed here
all right if i know how curry he's got
the same side high he's been doing it
all night no he's actually going other
side now
oh
i mean i'll be honest when i saw him do
all that i was probably going man
he was he was doing a little bit too
much trying to float in front of me
oh
okay i like that we play the league game
oh okay that was a great defensive
oh yeah absolutely baby that's great
jack
all right oh we get hit here
all right
gonna be able to go into a level three
yeah that must be possible get her as
close as possible
very smart all right he can run that
hurts this way
[Music]
[Music]
i want these 200 points i want to say i
want to get ahead of akari
i want that top spot if i'm hikari i'm
switching back to my team because he's
trying to play dr rose angels or you
could call them kasuga's angels
whichever one you want to call them and
it's not working right now right for me
beer is a little bit too solid for you
to try to use a team you're not
completely versatile how do you hold
them right now but here's the thing
right we gotta hope
that vermeer has the stamina all right
now he's playing what he has to play we
gotta hope that vermeer has the stamina
to go the distance remember this is one
set right but he has to play the next
one if he gets his reset he has to beat
him six times oh my goodness
to be technical right
he definitely he has to be on six times
yeah if he wants to win this tournament
[Music]
and that's not counting the matches he's
gonna lose right yeah so like
he's gonna be a lawyer
all i could say is that he has ten games
to do
let's hope he could do in six let's hope
he could do it at seven
he's gotta do it oh analogy
oh
about
all right i like the future right now
very fast
very fast pace barry has gotten four
music
drops
oh no
he didn't believe in 17 getting in the
hit right there
oh
oh
oh my god
all right
[Music]
you have to hope you can just get the
hit on vegeta as soon as
akari has to flame it out until 21
actually gets healthy
low-key i actually would have just taken
the switch
because the life would have been gone on
21 wow
you got the jump like
regardless but this blue light for 21
and like there's a chance it could all
come back and that's that's too much and
unfortunately it's well on its way he's
got a level three here
oh he's probably gonna get another
percent as this is happening she's
already back to seventy percent oh yeah
oh my god
damn
the blue lights and lost his own
character yeah
so this is like that is so hard he did
the right thing but it's like crap so he
wants healthy again
like it's it's like he did the right
thing but you have to think like
objectively you this is quite literally
you were stuck in between a rock and a
hard place
so
oh and back into the corner you go yes
we can oh wow surprise vermin there go
for involve there um it still would have
been a single he went for five days
does not care
yo
protect the people i love
yo every time you do the super afternoon
like animation is really good
you be coming out of broly's fist bro oh
he didn't believe oh believe me oh my
god
21 coming back with that full life bar
even though she got bodied earlier she's
like
and the funny thing is all the all the
damage because you know how the game
goes
yeah but we'll flash that
so you know how the game gives you
damage from losing like life and
everything it's so funny it's so funny
that like she's all hurt but she had a
full life
see right now i recovered nothing
happened
okay
oh wow
what are you doing
vermeer needs to just walk up on these
people who are walking on him
oh
that was that was a weird decision
anyway
yeah
surprise he didn't go he didn't go to
bnb there he chose vanish
seemed like he was cutting it short i
actually understand the decision there
it might have been it might have been um
the vanish maybe to try to reset him
with like ied um with ied uh jm yeah
well that we the world may never know
vermeer is up 2-0 it's not looking good
for hikari
it's a quick quick tour
wins this next one it's reset time
and reset time vermeer three on you he's
confident he got defense
and now vermeer pulled out the offense
too
now
i'm not gonna allow that game that round
that offense was like a really sick
and honestly vermeer's been making
choices like on wake up that he doesn't
usually make that embodied in a car my
man woke up 5h
that was crazy that was great it worked
though right we can't be mad
uh it was a double bond and android 6
and it was a double on the android 16
and you round star 5 8 because people
didn't know about anything you could do
round start to avoid those things what
should jvg
ssa vegeta a was a war zone we don't
talk about that if it was ridiculous but
back to this match though
that's what vermeer needs to start doing
he needs to start punishing hikari virgo
is reflect because akari has been
reflecting on streams and just
reflecting in general especially on
weight
on this wake up after level three he
might just reflect again i'm running up
and grabbing him
[Music]
see what he does here wow
okay
is he good he's gonna bring him vegeta
he could vanish here again nasty left
right
that's how you know he was desperate
he's like
quick
quick give me both assists oh i'm liking
this pressure from akari
[Music]
yeah it's funny i just raised the sixth
time i called it god like it was god
like that i'm not gonna lie it was a
very good it was a very well placed exam
[Music]
[Music]
i can't help but ask you vegito
i don't know you are a part of
circumstances
tech case but it doesn't matter because
vagina options
i actually like i actually like android
18 this position yes
yes
wow that was a mix
yeah that was a very low idea for the
ground
hey and we get one more i think we
forget to bring in vegeta
vegeta here
oh
yeah sea rocks i'm waving people
oh see rex shout out to oh oh
we can shout out real quick before we
get back
all right all right the party's getting
started here
i mean what's my grandmother this
character is done
[Music]
that mind you that keyblast is like
minus two
and because because it doesn't it
doesn't miss on small people anymore
it's uh it's really good because now you
can use it as a universal stagger
against everyone
all right he's gonna bring a 21. and i
like this
oh
[Music]
versatility not versatility durability
he has shown everybody even maybe you
mean endurance
wait i think there's another word for
that no because it's stamina so it'd be
endurance
durability or how hard you are
no no no yeah
the specific word i'm looking for is um
how even when they laugh no
you mean adaptability
not adaptability
when the goalie gets tough we stay in
the fight what's the word for that
that's it
it's not endurance dude are you ready
it's not about how hard you get is this
is how you get up
uh you know that good stuff
perseverance
hikari is still the perseverance of this
set yo
i'm sorry i'm scared
[Music]
[Laughter]
how bad
[Music]
and one oh spanish
you just said john john and john
oh my goodness super dad listen i'm
waiting for our assistant to just do it
make supernatural
so back to the match all right good
pressure hit my car miss all right
that was insane that was worth the
perseverance that was crazy that wasn't
worth the person the true mix bishop
this is what real vegito combos look
like okay
you know it's crazy it took for me to
get to grandparents to bust this one out
too because i haven't seen this combo
all day i'll be honest
man
look the car you guys start with some
block it's not easy he's not gonna go
very far he's not choosing
at all he's not truth as well
those two sentences was because he chose
a flag
that that's why i said so i said when
vermeer would start dealing with people
waking up reflex or specifically her car
in his matchups and it would do it would
do him justice it is in doing his entire
justice right now but you know what's
not going to do him justice this level
uh how are you about to get mixed
this is
my
that was so good because if he had
reflected that would have punished it
and that's what he was expecting to
happen
[Music]
nope he's four
and they're in the game right
all right okay you're good at this must
do it i'm going to steal this let's do
this ability
oh it's called toeing the line
it's insane to me that
there's been
every time vermeer has just chose block
against 21.
oh my god oh wow
this is not that you really staggered me
all right now we gotta get the good mix
right here oh yeah and we're getting the
same properties this could be very
dangerous right here
[Applause]
to this first thing
you know why josie
because he don't get his comeback on
them all right
he's still alive i'm going level four
no and berber with the grandfather's
it's possible vermeer's hot uh right now
the teams that hikari have been playing
the mode
haven't been working out for right
he he's not he's not really opening up
her mirror the way he wants to on
defense he's committing to reflect and
vermeer has been adjusting to it yeah so
he has to he has to figure something out
he has it for yourself
my question here is
can vermeer keep this momentum man i
think that's it
that's fatigue kicking
can you
because this level of play is amazing
but
can burnout kick in eventually i think
vermeer has as you would say
perseverance
i think he'll make it
i was clean that was clean
i think i think vermeer is like a very
strong mentor yeah and i think he's
gonna he could possibly make this
clueless uh if i'm herkari honestly i
think her car needs to switch to like
either like his team he's the most
comfortable with for a team that's just
even stronger in neutral than vermeer's
team loki i think he should do like ui
hit 21.
i think that team will work better for
him right i'll tell you so you want to
go full online
yeah like the highest level
do it
do it
i'm not gonna lie this team is has been
the team that hikari has been rocking
he's been successful with it
online and offline we we got to see how
he did offline so i say run into the
to the cops coming home man
already oh that's not good
oh wait hold up but he's gonna get a
combo though this is good
that's actually pretty good yeah
he needed to take it he needed to get
something for life
i think vermeer could definitely squawk
he got out
back yeah chase it down
oh
oh my god hakari has to stop panicking
with this reflection oh ow
ooh
[Applause]
and we gotta oh my god what's up i was
like that's definitely too much oh
i know 60 had no loops like that oh i'm
excited
i don't know why i don't know why are
you trying to touch it oh you see the
looks oh oh yeah yeah should we see
bring in the shimmy city oh
wow look at that
wow that was a godlike
[Music]
i got mixed man all right i ain't think
that was team gohan again oh my goodness
it's the rock paper scissors make sure
you keep rocks like
all right
remember that's already
um
[Music]
oh my god oh no
oh no
any switching to 21.
oh
no why didn't you switching to 21. she
has an air level 3 you fool
[ __ ] oh my god
i'm not gonna lie i think i would have
brought zeke rolly
actually broke here at the end of the
day man i'll leave him alive i would
have brought his early beat beside no so
what he needed to do was after the the
ex-8 he needs a combo pack in the 21.
oh
she needs to apply the cons she needs to
apply the command grab right no you can
do it with anything you can even just do
the tackle
oh you got mixed by the [ __ ]
if he does the tackle in that situation
right unfortunately the cooldown still
exists we can't dhc well he he doesn't
need to do that what he needs to do is
light light right
into the air level three because the air
level three had
oh wow
three here he had to bring in vegeta
again because at the end of the day 21
is dying
and this works you know what we take
that 50 percent that we got from broly
in the last touch oh yeah absolutely
oh
oh my god
this combo is so important oh yeah
oh the fronts are happy right now they
can't sleep but they they smiling in
their sleep and they're
they got the saint john's candle from
the shop if you've ever been to the shop
you know where the shop's at yo yo
uh-huh they got the little altar at home
they don't put you in light up the
candle they don't wrote your name on it
put it in this
now you're going to work with a
stomachache the next day
now so i will say um so
one thing is good is that hakari
actually found a kind little
[ __ ] and um
and vermin's dragon rush armor
that that was that was a couple because
he's been on it with the dragon brushes
man with second limit and all that stuff
so the reason why that works so well
against vermeer is because vermeer is
taking dragon rush with two out right so
that he could potentially either check
the dragon rush or get the hit so the
problem is that he sees the assist and
he doesn't want to take the risk of
getting hit if they're just doing
assists
so he he has to actually hold that
because the thing is it becomes a trade
situation right but we we win the trade
that the assistant you're exactly oh
my car is playing this game
oh no the child is adapting
[Laughter]
oh grabber oh now play harder
oh
so he tried to he tried to do the
anti-air grab to catch the back dash but
his character didn't turn around so he
oh
it's gonna be the miss input there yeah
yeah he did he didn't want that grad
specifically
oh no
he actually got he actually got the
situation he wanted too
but then they react to it
all right
yo hakari has great control of the match
right now
oh yeah
the kids just want to have fun oh yeah
wait wake up in the 50s oh yeah uh-huh
that was god like that that's [ __ ]
into that
it's a 21.
beautifully done
i believe we bring vegeta right back in
yes sir
all right yo akari is making all the
right decisions
having great reactions right now
if i will say this like one of my
favorites greatest rates yeah i mean can
it get
it
they'll lose a couple games and they
don't pick up on what he needs to do
it makes it worse and
i know this sounds like like a little
dramatic
he's like one of the few players that
really knows how to get inside the
mental of an opponent
through the video game like it's really
guy like to see something
he knows how to make them just crumble
oh oh
vermeer get hit by 6m now that's how you
know
like he just
i don't know how he does it like i've
seen it so many times you know we've
seen it so much a city man he just knows
how to get in the opponent's head
listen y'all talking about vermeer
getting tired y'all realize him in a car
we're in the same game
i mean it makes sense right
it makes sense right but you you have to
think about it the only difference is
probably like probably like the the
difference in games from the fact that
vermeer got sent to losers
earlier than him but other than that
they were both in the same tournament
carly's been up just as long as him
he hasn't been playing as long but he's
been out just as long as him
they haven't yeah they have been in the
same time frame they've been yeah it's
been they've been at this all day pretty
much but vermour has had to battle a
couple more battles to get every now
that's the problem like we're resetting
in grand finals it's like that kari has
three games to give you
to to potentially like even five games
to give
to to learn about his opponent's
playstyle and in fighting games every
match that you can to get information on
your opponent to him
absolutely two important that's the
thing right so like i believe if i'm not
mistaken vermin actually lost second
round
so he's been running this
i guess nothing but tough opponents too
[Music]
because you'll never go you won't go to
lose the second round right exactly
plays a part man but he physically
mentally
it's only so hard it's hard to play at
that level for so long oh my god that
that joy is terrible
oh
oh oh did you die
can't be close
oh you're dead
18 assists so up wow
oh
you thought this was your killing combo
but it's actually my killing problem
because i'm
i'm the better player the table is
actually turning this that was god
the tables turn on the turntable
oh my god
by the way i got mixed by the other day
[Laughter]
now he can he can have some fun with the
sparkling vegito
it looks like bremer taps back into that
wow he actually chose garcia
[Music]
so choosing the two more guard cancer is
actually really good now no of course
it's plus
all right level three
my goodness
i mean it's laughing at him he says this
is funny
oh yeah you're done
you're not you're not dead but you got
to do so much damage
oh my god what all right he wants a
cheeky setup
uh i don't know what that was
oh my god oh you saw that match oh my
goodness
he's able to cross him just inside
thankfully because that was like scary
i'm not gonna lie probably is big he
could have grabbed the toe too
wow
oh yeah
[Music]
i think he leveled he's got level three
just to keep
there's like a little bit of blue light
on here that you actually want to get
because that's like that's like the
difference between like uh
potentially
hey
oh my goodness i was so dangerous
my man's fighting for his life but it's
looking click i'll be real with you hold
up big man
nope yeah
wow
listen yo this new shoe can only hold
out for so long
and with that car he's gonna win the
grand finals reset three yo my man said
oh you three on me
i got sold for you
yo i'm so hot i'm so happy we don't have
like an open call because you know who
you're calling us right now
man hakari be there yo for me
i let you get three games you gotta say
his voice
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
yo this is big this this um
he might just be a shooting he might
just be in france we'll see if he does
his homework we'll see if he can get if
you get your friends because you gotta
understand he was already top two
entering this bracket
to
pretty much qualify right
he just won the masters challenge which
means he adds 200 points
to his to his name
he was only i believe before this
tournament started like 40 points behind
dismantle it
definitely above dismantle actually
funny enough vermeer moved above this
mantle with this tournament now
this mantle is out the running right now
he has to catch up to those two well
it's still quite possible so don't
forget guys right of course of course so
this was the tenkaichi online master
challenge there's only one of them for
each region right
so he uh hakari takes the 200 points for
mayor takes the 150 [ __ ] takes the 100
um right but that's not the end of the
world championship tenkaichi online
events
right they're still running until
november so if you guys can enter your
locals right the more people that enter
the more chances people have to catch up
64 entrants in a tournament that's 100
points right that means if you enter 264
264 tournaments and you get first at
each boom you won your tenkaichi event
and remember we're taking the top 10
placements of each person for every
tournament so enter as many as you can
even if you do bad one tournament as
long as your top 10 entrants are better
than that tournament they will drop so
it's very important that you guys don't
give up all right even though i want to
see a car
don't forget guys right so the regional
finals 45th of december are the regional
finals for europe 11th and 12th of
december regional for the us 18th and
19th are the regional finals for japan
[Laughter]
all right
oh and this is very important for the
regional finals breakdown 12 players are
going to be there for each region eight
invited players
plus four spots from the qualifiers from
the online tenkaichi
event
all right so there's a round robin
format into a final bracket into the
regional champion
and just to clarify just to clarify
something um for the qualifiers in the
usa there's two there's gonna be two
from the west coast two from the east
coast just in case there were anywhere
guys oh there's the page right there
people's giving you a breakdown of who
who which places is gonna qualify for
those for those reasons final oh exactly
look at that
that's your that you're a top four
looking kind of schnitzy bro i wonder
who are they
i want to see who's coming from brazil
in the middle in the middle east that's
what i want to see i'm very excited i'm
very excited to see pretty much the
mexico australian brazilian brazilian
brazil
all right all right it's done everyone's
tired it's tired tyra's supposed to be
asleep i think it's uh it's about that
time
it's about that time dad i want to thank
everybody who came out uh watch the
dragon ball fighterz arena seven
tenkaichi master challenge i want to
thank posie for being out here with me i
want to thank tyron for uh running
everything from behind the scenes want
to thank bandai namco for having us
again one thing everybody who watched
you guys are absolutely amazing i know
there were some people from europe in
the chat even though that this is like 3
a.m in the morning for them or or
something close to that they definitely
i love their support man we really
appreciate that yeah you guys are
absolutely absolutely amazing um we
wouldn't be here without you guys cozy
you will wrap us up so say your words
that we were going to head out
i just want to say well i god guys stop
tui filming like i really really
appreciate it not this year i really
really appreciate guys having us here i
really appreciate shout outs to siren
shout outs to damascus you know shout
out to bum but for giving us a start you
already know man i appreciate this event
and um i hope to do more
i hope i could go to france one day i
got i gotta see the friends the french
guys see me all right i hope they come
to new york one day too it's my little
message to them y'all got us but
hopefully we can get that run back i
beat up their commentators
i'm sorry for this
that's kind of crazy hello don't forget
you guys can follow me on twitter
acoustics as i commentate more events in
the future and you could follow me on
twitter on posyunderscore92 if you guys
want to check him check it with my
streams i like to host um good offline
sessions with the new york players the
best i could bring daiku's nitro june
sometimes pride when he comes out of
long island so definitely follow me on
twitch.tv
92 we greatly appreciate it follow
cousins on twitch too yeah i dropped my
link in the chat i'm cloud
nonetheless guys thank you have a great
night we appreciate the time here cool
bring us home baby that said you have a
great night i want to thank everybody
coming out
and that brings the end to the arena
seven tenkaichi online master chat
[Laughter]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you